hello everybody Doug Walker here and
welcome to The Last Airbender view logs
as you can tell this is aftershock right
after I did the intro so I have seen the
very first episode the boy in the
iceberg and first impressions I guess
because it's interesting a lot of people
say well once you watch it you're really
gonna be like sucked in you want to see
more and more and more I didn't know I
don't know if this is started off as
like a movie where they run some of the
episodes together um and the first
episode is very good it's very creative
I will admit it didn't it didn't suck me
in like something like lost or Game of
Thrones did but then again it is a
Nickelodeon show which everyone says
like oh no this totally changes you know
like the way Nickelodeon shows looks and
I believe it because it is a very
impressive looking show what what did
sort of throw me I don't want say throw
me for a loop and it's not totally fair
to say this but and maybe it's a good
thing bad thing is that watching the
first episode I had to sort of remind
myself oh yeah this is for kids I think
there's something about the the design
and even kind of the pacing and the
layout where it's sort of fools you into
almost thinking like oh yeah this this
is a movie you know there's a scene
where they're looking inside this looks
like a submarine and it's very quiet and
they got these great angles and there's
no talking and no music you just hear
the echoes of the ship and it'll be
interesting from here on to see if this
is like see if the rest of the show goes
like this of course I'll have you
probably already know but as someone
just coming in uh I was impressed by it
and I think somebody also going in with
a lot of hype behind it it's probably
not the best way to go in I realize
because automatically you're gonna be
like well that first episode didn't
totally pull me in and stuff like that
but again it's a series and it's an
intro uh and for you know for an intro
it was very interesting and literally as
it begins it says like you know a
foreign nations the fire nations the
earth nations the
art nations I'm sure everybody's made
that joke um but they're given this
backstory and for something a Tom I got
our kids gonna be able to follow this
this is like a lot to take in and then
immediately goes to uh you know the
brother and sister who are making jokes
and you know the sir sound the brother
especially is a beautiful wisecracker
and stuff I'm circling oh yeah that's
right kick it show but I get that's the
ballot that that's what you got to put
up with I realize and I like the fact
that um I
they sound like kids the brother not not
quite so much maybe he's a teenager but
but these sound like real kids I don't
know they're played by adults or not but
they do a good job and I think we'll
grab me the most or what I find the most
interesting outside the designs of the
background of those are looking
wonderful uh is the animation itself and
the animation is very much obviously
anime influenced to a point where people
can probably confuse it for anime but
you can definitely tell it's American
and there is something about American
motion and Japanese motion that is very
different because Japanese motion seems
to be they put all their animation into
the action and you like all of it and
then the rest of it is like you know
that there's a lot close-ups like this
of somebody talking and looking at
something you don't see the mouth moving
because all the animation went into the
action but what's so clever bars that
they hide it very well by getting very
stylized shots and stylized angles
American animation is much more about
the motion so here you have them
constantly constantly in motion though
it's interesting because you could
probably see where certain arguments
came up particularly in the humor
because like when somebody is shocked by
something usual American animation will
do like three frames of a person huh
like that where Japanese enemies will
just have a prison here in the next
frame he's here so and you see that
happen here a few times like when eyes
open up it's not like you know there's a
frame or two of it opening up it's just
open uh and that's a stylistic choice I
know it's just prior to happenes
animation so
it's an interesting balance this is
probably so far one of the more
interesting balances between sort of
japanese-style the American style that
I've seen not that I've seen much
nickelodeon anime imitation shows uh
okay for example i did see a little bit
of that show Teen Titans and not not the
newer whatever the whatever the one that
came out like one five six years ago
something like that maybe him over I
came out and I was obviously trying to
you know mimic anime uh with all the big
over-the-top stuff in the big sweat drop
and stuff like that I can't stand that I
know that's a style if you like great it
drives me insane this is a lot this is a
nice medium I like the medium that they
have here is sometimes the the comedies
a little awkward again maybe cuz I'm
just not used to that really quick
animation maybe a warm-up to it um but
so far it's an interesting intro and any
has a lot of mystery behind it gives you
the backstory but at the same time you
know Oh was Eckley is the story behind
this Prince guy and why are the fire why
is the Fire Nation a bunch of a-holes
and and why are they looking to take
over and you know how is the war going I
like stories where something really big
is going on out there some sort of big
battle and yet the you know identifiable
characters the the young people are off
somewhere and they want to help and they
can't you know until something comes
along to throw them in there but it's
not it's not quite hammered in as much
as you know a lot of other shows and
movies like to do it um and the fact
that it is a show allows so much more
time you know like I don't know are they
gonna are they gonna go the North Pole
is that the next episode I mean I like I
like not knowing anything about this
show going in so that's it I don't know
how many the comments and go to read
because I know some people may give it
away and I want you guys to feel free to
you know comment and talk about it but
the last thing I'll say before I sign
off here is the about the first episode
is the you know I was talking about the
designs all of the animals in this I've
only seen I think
- now one is a giant flying bison with
just Crouch for creativity man as
weird and the other is which I
find this so strange
they're penguins they just say they're
penguins but they're clearly not regular
penguin penguin look like a mix between
Penguins and otters and and they sled on
them and I like that I like that they
serve create a world that's similar to
ours but it's also one that can kind of
interact in in their own way even the
the avatar boy seems very step giving up
using his legs you know or whatever
standing up he can just use his power
the wind power just to sort of have the
wind push him up I love little touches
like that or there's a seam the girl
gets really angry and she accidentally
bends the water behind her and cracks it
and isn't even where she does a little
things like that those are great touches
I think it makes a world much more
believable and livable and maybe that's
one of the big attractions about the
show I don't know I have to see but it
was a good first episode and of course
finally get to see make oh I know it's
mock oh but everyone's called him Makos
I'm just gonna stick to that because
that's the joke now I guess um and
finally see him as the princes uncle I
don't know I'm sure a lot of you gonna
shoot me out for it um but and yeah boy
something about because this was the
show everyone when I first made the Mako
joke everybody said that that's the guy
from Avatar come on come on and it is
century because he sounds so different
from something like when he did splinter
in the Ninja Turtles movie uh sorry
about that he's out a little bit more
slurred and sort of like half-awakened
this might sound very he sounds very
dignified and you know like a warrior
that's been through a lot but still has
a good sort of sense of humor too so I'm
even just seeing a few bits of that
character I see what people sort of
admired about his performance because I
can already hear it I'm like this guy's
like this far the most interesting
character so far I just want to know
what his story is and Urey feel so that
conflict of you know should he help this
Prince should he'd sort of you know make
it compromise with his teachings or sure
he you know really stick to what he
knows is right but you know time is of
the essence and lives are at stake and
it's good stuff as so I know it's a lot
to say just for the first episode but
it's interesting um if I didn't I want
me if I didn't have the hype around it I
don't know if I'd be like I have to see
the next episode uh but I do want to see
the next episode of curiosity I want to
know where it goes I like this kid I
like the sister he's a little weird um
just to see if he gets better but um yes
I look forward to see where it goes uh
that's episode one I'll see you for
episode two